ahna was not the girl that you see in
this movie when she was first on the
page that was this infusion of me saying
can I really play the girl that I needed
to see when I was 10 years old someone
who was really goofy kind of a weirdo
very klutzy wore her heart on her sleeve
I need to represent that girl for me for
me as a little girl and they were like
yes absolutely so there's so much
thought behind and heart behind these
movies we'll never be able to get out of
our heads and for good reason but the
question is can we expect a new
unforgettable ballad from frozen to this
time around we weren't in a panic like
we were in the first one so we got to do
things the way they're supposed to be
done which is talking and talking and
talking about story everything was in
full collaboration here's everything you
need to know before you go
[Music]
our hearts are frozen from the Disney
hit that blasted into our lives in 2013
[Music]
anyway everyone knows the hit let it go
it transcends genres it's hard to think
of another song that has meant so much
to a film and a generation of kids and
adults just think of all the ways the
phrase has been used
it literally sparked its own meme
culture on the Internet
there are so many ways you can let it go
don't get me started did you know that
frozen was based off Hans Christian
Andersen's fairy tale The Snow Queen in
case you haven't seen it or just need a
reminder of what happened in the film it
may seem like Elsa the ice queen of
arendelle is the protagonist but the
2013 film does a great job of showing
her sister Anna as the hero she may not
be able to manipulate ice but her
special powers lie in her bravery
strength and loyalty so here's a little
more background Anna and Elsa are the
daughters of the king and queen of
arendelle Elsa discovered she had the
power to control and create ice and snow
so in order to protect their children
the king and queen separated the
princesses from each other within the
castle listen to me Elsa
your power will only grow there is
beauty in it
but also great danger you must learn to
control it
fear will be your enemy
they were also shielded from the public
eye and the separation of the sisters
caused some resentment and distance in
their relationship unfortunately when
Anna and Elsa were teens their parents
died in a shipwreck at sea did you know
there was a conspiracy theory going
around online that the king and queen
were the parents of Tarzan another
Disney character we were doing an
interview and I naively said you know
[Music]
the story picks up speed after Elsa
becomes the queen embarrassed and afraid
of the backlash from accidentally
releasing her powers she decides to
become a recluse in her own self-made
Ice Mountain but in doing so she sets
off an eternal winter and Arundale deep
deep snow with the help of Kristoff his
Rangers Fenn and Olaf the snowman who
was mistakenly brought to life by Elsa's
magic set off to get Elsa to undo the
spell the twists and turns of the story
caused the sisters to reunite and once
again have a formidable bond Disney
approached this sequel knowing that the
fans of the original are now six years
older so the writers had to consider
that they are now playing to a more
mature audience who are likely preteens
now during a recent press preview
director Jennifer Lee talked about their
approach in creating this new story for
the sequel she said we realized there
were lingering questions within us we
wondered what Anna would do now that she
has everything she ever wanted we felt
there were unanswered questions about
their parents and where their ship was
going when it went down and the biggest
one why was Elsa born with magical
powers in frozen - it looks like Elsa is
gonna seek out the origins of her powers
in hopes that those answers will save
arendelle from a new threat
with ties to both Elsa and Anna's
parents we do know that the original
cast is back Kristen Bell as Anna
idina menzel is Elsa jonathan groff as
Kristoff Josh GAD is Olaf Evan Rachel
Wood plays Queen Adina the mother of
Anna and Elsa did you know director
Jennifer Lee voiced the Queen's one-line
in the previous film and joked about it
saying we actually had to fire the
original actors who played a Doudna from
frozen because she just couldn't cut it
Stirling Kate brown also joins the cast
as lieutenant Dustin Mateus he's been
trapped in the enchanted forest for 30
years this place seems to be at the core
of the new film's plot so I can't wait
to see this and here's some sweet new
music you think that the film's main
song into the unknown will be the new
let it go so now you know and now you
can go see frozen 2 in theaters November
22nd
[Music]